welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm joined by adam richardson who
is the co-founder of strive sales
they are a software sales recruitment
company that focus on the emea market
they're based in manchester currently
have 10 people in the business
and have big plans for the future adam
thanks for joining me
thanks for having me i mean uh and
obviously i know you're in a wee work
you're in a nice meeting room and i'm in
a
a nice foam beef cupboard yeah well
i opted out of the phone booth today
because yes the weather's quite nice and
uh
i didn't fancy sitting there for an hour
sweating my back out so
how um how have you found it being being
back in the office
um well me and harrison pretty much for
the majority of the lockdown just coming
coming in the two of us
me sat at home was just getting zero
work done and harrison's like an
absolute workhorse so
he wasn't happy being in the office on
his own so he dragged me in those states
but we were just doing reduced hours
um but a few weeks off to start with and
then got straight back in the mix and
yeah pretty much the two of us have just
been trying to graft our way through it
and is it has it been is it busy in the
because you're in is it some peter's
square in manchester is it that one
we're in dalton place and it's been dead
it's still quiet now
there's one other business on this on
the floor at the moment a lot of people
have
uh given notice that we're out of place
yeah quite a few of them um and then i
think they're like trying to come back
and renegotiate new deals so
um it's quite quiet there's there's not
many people in the building
yeah because i'm in a shared office
space in um an office group building and
definitely the same super quiet have you
got any of those uh
screens in the office around desks than
that
have you seen them yeah i saw them i i
saw
it on linkedin comment but like
yeah obviously they're important but i
don't know
i'm not sure if i'm a fan no i mean
there's we
you know we've got there's only a small
team and some of the guys that are in
our team are actually considered as high
risk or have got high-risk parents so
for the ones that we've come back we
just said if you want to come in come in
if you don't you want to work from home
that's cool yeah cool well adam where
we're always like to start in this
podcast is um
how does adam richardson enter the world
of recruitment let's start there
yeah so i think it's like most
recruiters no one sort of
you know sits down with a career advisor
at school and says you know let's get
into recruitment
um i graduated from university and did a
business degree
didn't really enjoy it to be honest and
but just just you know go on with it and
got it finished as
quickly as i could and by the time i
graduated harrison
i went to school with harrison he was
living um in beethoven tower
below the neville brothers like third
from the top driving around in this
white sports car convertible
earning like a load of money and um i
was like
how have i come out of uni with a load
of debt last time you know you were a
bricklayer when i left you and now he's
like living there so
it was recruitment so that's how i got
introduced to recruitment
and he introduced me to john and alex at
liquid
uh first time around they knocked me
back um had like
three like grueling interviews where
they just ripped me to shreds
um and and yeah in the end of it they
said no so go and get some sales
experience and
we might consider so i ended up working
in a call center for for nine months
um just looked on a dialer smashing
phones out all day
what did you tell them um ppi personal
injury claims
like yeah pretty much you know your
ambulance chase the kind of roles but it
you know it gave me a lot of good sales
skills to start off with
um but yeah random back after three
months they knocked me back again rang
them back after six months they knocked
me back again
and then john rang me after nine months
and by this point i'd like
i was like top performer in the office
and it was managing a team
and it's like right you know you're
ready to come in so they offered me a
job but
you know they had to then give me a
higher base and guarantees and stuff so
it probably worked out for the best
i love that so demonstrating a bit of
resilience before we
enter the world of recruitment yeah i
don't know why i didn't just apply
somewhere else
like i just saw harrison's car and
thought i need a piece of that so yeah
and uh
to be fair like alex and john they did
absolutely rinse me
and i thought you know what that's like
brutal in the interviews you know the
two guys that i definitely want to work
for in it and it all works out in the
end
so just for context for everyone so
harrison is now your
obviously that's obviously a
long-lasting relationship but he's your
the person that you started strive sales
with right just for context for people
listening
and then john and alex are actually uh
there's
um two chats that are actually obviously
involved in your business as well
yeah so me and harrison we went to
school together we pretty much worked
together our entire career
um so we worked together with with
liquid with a uh with a to zed
and he came he was involved with insight
helped massively with from a bd
perspective and then also from
internal recruitment perspective and
then when we started strive as its own
brand
that was very much harrison's focus and
to which i've sort of later
later parted ways with insight to focus
100 and strive so
i pretty much have known him since i was
10 we're born a day apart
i'm definitely his mum's favorite son
and then yeah alex and john you know
they give me my first shot in
recruitment same with harrison he took
harrison on when he was 17
he offered to work for free um and then
and then yeah ten ten years later
they've um they're now like
investors in the business directors and
uh
helping us sort of scale the business
with plans to take it internationally
yeah what what is that such an interest
like how it's all sort of
come full circle i think it's super
interesting and
we're gonna dive into that but just
quickly as we're talking about it
how much has it helped how much has it
helped
being in business with someone that no
doubt you have a lot of trust
in um so trust yeah it helps
um you know i've been quite fortunate in
my career i've
i've always worked with like like great
people harrison being one of them sean
was great he was always
you know i never had any doubt of trust
with sean um but yes
with harrison in particular you know i
know he's there for the highs and when
when things have gone horribly wrong
he's still sort of stayed true to
himself
and been there by my side but i think
having that relationship when you've
been mates with someone you know we used
to wag school together um
that also means that you know it comes
with its uh its flaws so we thicker like
a married couple um
but i know he's got my best interests at
heart and so have i
no i love that so let's talk a bit about
liquid personnel so saw the
harrison's flashy car one in the piece
of that
how how always interested like what what
was your
recruitment experience like then at
liquid overall like did you
was it tough did you did you smash it
straight away what was the the jerk
because how long was your liquid
about about two years or so yeah my
experience at liquor was great i learned
a lot
um john was john was more sort of behind
the scenes operational alex was very
much the you know the guy on the sales
floor the sales leader
he was one that trained me and sort of
taught me
taught me the rope so to speak so from a
learning perspective i learned a lot
and i had a lot of success quite quickly
at liquid
um you know i was doing deals within i
think month three
and then just really pushed on from
there and um
you know i think just before i left how
i left liquid was was
quite bizarre because i came off the
back of three record months i did a
sixth placement month all new placements
nine placement month
all new placements and then a third team
which was the record at the time i don't
know is this contract
yeah okay contracts i don't know if it
is now
um i got a promotion on the monday spent
pretty much
all day with my manager at the time dave
and alex sort of business planning
talking about my future and the next
steps and growing this
grow my desk even more met for lunch
with harrison on the tuesday and then
quit on the friday
[Laughter]
so alex and dave assuming um
like yeah they weren't happy and
yeah so just quickly on on that and then
we'll
talk about um you leaving and stuff
um obviously from what i under from the
context i have from liquid
was it was that health care what was it
it was social work social media
they branched off into into a lot more
sort of broader across the sort of
healthcare
spectrum but at the time it was just 100
contract social work
i looked after the south west so from
uh gloucestershire to hampshire over to
cornwall
um and just focused on anything social
works of
child protection and adult social care
as well how big was the business by the
time you left
when i left we so when i started were
above a takeaway on princess street i
think there was about
15 consultants 20 consultants
and it was still like a bit of a boiler
room and you know it was great
and then we moved down the road to
another like it was like the first
proper office that yeah
they had and i think it was only in
there a few months and then i left so
i think when i left was probably about
including all the the
business support back off to you back
office team
probably about 40 people okay so just
quit on before we move on
why why was it that adam
set records compared to others like why
why why did you why did you achieve that
um i wouldn't profess to have been like
you know some god's gift to recruitment
because there was people in there that
are out billing me
um i was i was up there and
i think i had a bit of fluke better luck
um
but the operation they had at liquid
enabled you to be really successful
um the business support team was amazing
so
i didn't have to do anything that didn't
involve selling
um we had our own like like personal
business support for each team
um girl called helen she pretty much did
all
all of like my admin and anything that
wasn't phone based or selling and
she did forage which was great was just
allowed me to just spend all day on the
phone
and you know do do my job so i think it
was
at the time i was very young driven
money hungry and
you know alex could easily tap into what
my drivers were
um and i was really competitive
and i just when i started i just there
was a guy that
when i got knowed they offered another
guy and when i joined i was like who was
it that he gave the jobs but he was like
the first target
and i just picked up the consultants one
by one and
and that that was it so it was really
really really competitive and i was a
cocky little [ __ ] at the time
so i think yeah a bit of you know drive
very
driven competitive but i think the
infrastructure that they had there
allowed people to go in and
focus on what they enjoy and so they
gave you the platform and tools
yeah absolutely so i think there's a bit
of a product
product of my environment a little bit
and then also just
i think yeah my natural competitive
nature
i've got a very competitive and
entrepreneurial group of friends so
we're always trying to outdo each other
so that i think that helped
what was the best piece of advice you
received in those two years
um
advice struggle to think about advice i
think
that that to sort of twist your question
in terms of influence and person that
really
like helped and mentored me was yeah it
was it was alex
i mean i was quite fortunate my my
manager at the time my team manager
he was the top miller in the office so
like in terms of setting an example
he worked his ass off he was first in
last out every day
we had a great relationship um so i had
that as an example to be working towards
and then alex was just
he was relentless um and he didn't
accept
any form of mediocrity so um yeah i mean
the first six months of my job
i was just constantly in fear of losing
it like i joined i bought that bought my
first house like a few months you know
alex had just bought a house like
am i gonna pass my probation he wouldn't
tell me until the day
until six months in bearing a man had
like done everything he asked me to
so he always kept me on my toes um but
it was yeah i think
in terms of advice i probably couldn't
put my finger on something but in terms
of like having role models mentors and
people that
really set the example liquid was full
of them there was
there was no one in there that what
didn't deserve the seat at the table
yeah so the standards are really high
and uh always encourage you to be
the best version of yourself and nothing
less yeah
when i joined there was like a bit of a
change of guard there was like people
that have been there for a few years and
like as i joined a few of them left so
like even like people that have been
there from day one started to leave
and like the new new sort of fresh blood
started to to come through
um so yeah everyone in there was
was was doing well there was no one
blanking any months everyone was
hitting and smashing the targets pretty
much every month for the first few years
was like
a record-breaking month for us in terms
of revenue new deals written up so
it was a great environment um so i
really enjoyed it
so then you left on the friday you and
harrison yeah harrison also told you the
dream
no you know what what went for lunch we
went to lunch
and he took me to his office and um he'd
gone to like typical harris and he got
like the swankiest office in chancery
play so we're like rubbing shoulders a
lot so
he's left liquid by this point right
he's left yeah
and like we're you know with all these
like
corporate lawyers and i was like what
the [ __ ] are you doing in there
on your own so that was it and
it was bizarre because yeah i went i was
speaking to my girlfriend at the time i
had this like
weird dream on my teeth had fallen out
the night before which apparently means
that you're worried about money and i
just
i didn't think about it too much i just
thought well
i'm young enough i'm not married i don't
have any kids i bought my first house
and
the worst that can happen is i lose my
house and i have to move back into my
dad's spare room so i can deal with that
at 22.
so just so let's just frame up so let's
see so joined harrison on his endeavors
what so what did you what was it that
you and harrison did because it was what
like two
to three years was it somewhat like yeah
so
as i mentioned before i got into
recruitment i worked in a call center
one of the things that i did really well
in the call center was that the
um accident management so if anyone had
an accident i was like
really good at getting you know getting
the claims and getting the hires and
getting all that sorted out harrison
have been introduced to someone who
could
basically connect us to that network and
i knew how to
i knew the pitch and i knew how to sell
it so i
joined and we started off doing your rta
claims and then ppi
claims and then debt management and then
the business really took off when we got
introduced to a developer
um random as anything something like
hippie based in australia
built this credit brokering platform
which allowed someone to go on a website
apply for a loan and rather than have to
apply for a loan for like
10 different banks we just did one with
us and we'd ping them off to say 20
lenders
as soon as they got a loan we got
commission and it it
there was no phones involved it was all
online and like a click of a button you
could just increase and decrease the
amount of applications you got so we got
um
we we invested quite a bit of money into
that platform
with a developer we'd never met um and
yeah that's when the business really
started to to sort of take off
in terms of like the the money that we
were making at the time
okay was that all ethical
yeah yeah yeah all like fully regulated
so
like the two pretty young lads we were
regulated by the moj
the uh fca all of them it has that
stigma doesn't it
just like all that yeah yeah so
that was i think it was we because we
had all of the licenses and regulations
that's actually what led to selling the
business
okay so that's so that's how then that
journey sort of ended as you
exited that or sold it yeah so
we um we were one of the first brokers
in the country to get the full
fca license it was quite a long process
we we invested a lot of money into a
compliance company to help us get it
and when we got it a lot of other
companies were struggling
uh to get the license which meant we
wouldn't have been able to trade past a
certain point
so as soon as we got the license pretty
much all the big boys wanted to
just buy the company so that they had
the license that they could trade
so um sort of back end of 2014
early 2015 we sold it to one of the big
players in the brokerage market
and how long does that take you to do
how long did you do that for
the sale yeah no yeah no how long did it
how long did you
have that business for sorry 2012 to
2015.
okay so just a quick one and then we can
get back to
recruitment like as you said
adam 20 22 years old got a house
girlfriend nothing to lose
where did this sort of i guess where did
this sort of fearlessness come from
no doubt you you and harrison would be
like what the [ __ ] are we doing here
we have no idea what we're doing we're
winging it you're making money you're
not making money you're learning you're
investing
like where where did that come from do
you think like how how did you navigate
through that
just yeah how was you so willing to take
risks and be fearless
i don't know i think i'm either easily
led by harrison or there's something
else going on
no i mean you know my my dad's always
like
i've been employed always work for
someone whereas my mum has been more of
the entrepreneurial person she's worked
for herself since she was like 16 so
um i don't know just saw my mum always
like
you know just not yeah winging it all of
her
career and she you know she did a good
job of me my brother and my sister so
maybe it came from that um but yeah i'm
pretty driven money motivated
you know i've always wanted more and
more and i also get quite i get bored
quite easily do the same thing
so i i know when i left liquid even
though i was still on that like
upwards curve there was days where i
started to get a bit bored doing the
same thing i always need to sort of
challenge myself which
is a good thing but it's also quite a
bit of a downfall with myself sometimes
you know start something and struggled
to not always finish it i was looking
for the negative
yeah yeah yeah yeah which is i suppose
one of the
one of the the reasons why i've had
success but also why some things haven't
worked out
trying to sort of do too much but i
think over the years i've learned to say
no
so then obviously entered the the world
of recruitment again
right so as you know i had sean on the
podcast so obviously so just to frame up
for everyone
yeah um so involved in insight for
a couple of years and then obviously
then as you said then focused on strive
sales
just to help me out what was the time
frame of that just
it just helps with context so was
involved a lot more with insight for how
long before
strive yeah yeah so and me and sean
we've been friends for years he used to
dj
at sanki's so everyone always asks how
did you meet and expecting like some you
know big grand
career you know we used to dominate his
s3 like no
he used to dj sanki's when i was at uni
i was good friends with his brother
and i think we had that many sort of
drunken chats about setting up a
recruitment company that it just
eventually ended up happening so um we
got together like back end of 2015 and
set up insight
and sean was leaving s3 you've been
there for like 15 years
um and then had a bit of a restructuring
and
you know one reason or another he took
that as an opportunity to leave
so set up insight from day one sean did
perm
i did contract um and then yeah i was
there for
four years uh left in october last year
officially um after four years
from two of us in my old office in
stockport where i had a to z
um to think it was about 35 40
full-time people when we uh when i left
so let's definitely um let's just talk
about that for a second then
how what for you personally then what
was that
how did you deal with and cope with that
transition of going from
selling what you was to contract
recruitment in tech right
yeah how did you manage that it was a
shock to the system
you know i had i'd not recruited for
four years
i'd not um i'd never recruited it
i'd dealt with developers because we had
developers that did all the loan
brokerage platform
so i had an understanding of developers
i didn't understand
tech so to speak but um
just yeah we spent a few weeks just
getting everything in order
crms the company website all that lot
and then
when sean got back from barbados he'd
been away for these with his wife and
his kids for a few weeks
we just got on the phones he gave us um
he gave me like a job spec that we
pulled on off one of the job boards and
said right start speaking to some people
about that job
um and there was a few if i think about
how i'd sort of learn about
the tech like once you know to recruit
you know to recruit yeah
um it's like riding a bike but
how i learned the market there was there
was a couple of candidates very early on
that i got
quite pally with that lived near near to
me and i just
yeah i just was like a sponge and if i
had if i came up against anything i
didn't understand i'd just ring them
and i was always honest with them yeah
um and i think
yeah they just said unless i'm new to
this market this is what i'm about
you know can you help me and they were
always like they'd always
take the time to help me out i think a
lot of people underestimate
how you like that you can do that you
know what i mean because i think
sometimes people can make the assumption
or worry that
are they going to think i'm not
competent or they're not going to do you
know what i mean
so i think people sometimes
underestimate sort of how willing people
to help and how much knowledge you can
actually soak up from people
most people like to help the ones that
don't
you know you're always going to get
those people but most people like the
feeling of
being more knowledgeable about something
and being able to help
so yeah i think it's a powerful word you
pick up the phone i need your help
you know it takes a certain kind of
person to say no sanji you're on your
own
so what how i'd like to break this down
a bit before we go on to strive is um
just the sort of beginning part of
insight
obviously i have a bit of context
because i've sat down with sean a while
ago but
a lot of people listen to this podcast
who maybe long term might be thinking
about starting a recruitment business
or early on at the moment what happened
in that first year that you didn't
expect
um we grew quickly
we filled jobs
we moved into like amazing office space
we had like one of one of the best
things of the first year was like the
group of people that we actually ended
up like
with as our like founding team were all
like just great people i love going to
work with them every day
and i got on with every single one and i
respected them all so much like the
first to beat the trip that we did
with the guys was just like that was the
thing with me
um i think one of the like defining
moments of
the business um which really was like
quite a big turning point was when we
did our first event
because we sean was obviously always big
into his events you know we had his own
united stand
that was like his thing so when we
started looking at doing the events it
was definitely something that was
playing to our strengths
um and the first one that we did at
seven brothers
was just like without blowing our own
trumpets we just we smashed it for our
first
considering we're a new agency um you
know we've not been going that long
we you know they think there's about 80
90 people that turned up the panel were
amazing
no one had really been doing that in
manchester um at that time
you know we were one of the first to
sort of do to do one of these kind of
events
um and off the back of the event we did
loads of business
you know record-breaking fee off the
back of one of the events
um new client signs and great
relationships and i think that really
sort of
accelerated putting us on the map um in
manchester because you know let's be
frank there's
there's a lot of you know tech
recruitment companies in manchester
um but that that was a real turning
point and then
from then i'm just pushing on the event
and it yeah
it was a real door opener for us yeah
yeah and i know sean spoke a lot about
that
and and i think just a quick one on that
i'd love to get your perspective of this
adam and then let me ask you one or two
more things and we're going to
strive like you know when you say
business big big fee off the back of it
or whatever
like a lot of people listening or a lot
of recruiters perceptions will be
how how can hosting a running event
make me money so like like
i mean i obviously have my opinion sort
of the know-how from the conversations
that i have but
like when you say that like how did that
happen
is it because you're able to call people
and say hey got this event start a
relationship
is it because at the event you then got
someone's business card i don't know
what like how did that actually
generate because we're talking marketing
and return on investment here yeah so
like how did that actually happen
so let's be frank it's it's relevant now
more than ever
if you're just going out there trying to
make placements in this market
and not trying to think about how you
can add value to clients
and candidates that doesn't involve you
in making an immediate placement
you you're going to struggle there's
going to be people out there that are
going to sort of really start to
accelerate so
let's be frank the whole purpose of the
event was to market our brands
to build relationships with clients and
candidates that would result in fees
but how we did it is we are we
positioned it as we were
we were giving clients a platform to
promote themselves and their brand
and giving candidates an opportunity to
meet with companies
that they may not have been able to get
a foot in the door
just off the back of their cv or you
know
that that was the sort of the pitch the
placement that we did
off the back of the first event was it
was planned out
one of my clients wanted to leave so i
said well we're hosting this event
let's get your name out of manchester
and off the back of it someone in the
crowd
said i want to meet him i want to hire
him so it worked a tree
but the whole thought process and how we
pitched it to our clients was
we're giving back to the community we're
creating a platform for businesses to
promote their brand into the local
community
and talk about what they're doing and
and and how
you know they're a great place to work
and the exciting place to work and
giving candidates an opportunity to meet
with companies
without any sort of formality of an
interview or
having to send their cv and
and that that was it so trying to do
something for nothing which
in the long term always always benefited
us
yeah no i like that okay and
why that's relevant now is if if you're
just trying to go after fees now in this
market
and not trying to think about how can i
add value to this client
and get offered them something that they
need right now that's going to help them
in their business
you're not going to build new
relationships and the relationships that
you've got probably going to start to
see through that it's
that value-based relationship that
you've been talking about is really just
purely transactional
and i think from the conversations i've
had been having i think
what sort of link it back to the event
and stuff i think
sometimes what recruiters forget is that
the actual value like which is really
significant
that you bring to the table is actually
being able to connect people
and that doesn't always mean for a fee
right like what you've done there and
you can
this is a big part of what's been going
on now loads of webinars live events
these types of things and that's because
as a recruiter what you're going to be
way more knowledgeable
than any client or candidate is is the
market and
sort of how one business is dealing with
things compared to another
and i think sometimes recruiters forget
that one of the great pieces of value
that you bring is actually being able to
um bring people that are having similar
challenges or
thinking about certain things to
actually hear or learn
or speak to other people that are in the
same boat
and being able to sort of connect those
people connect the dots and enable
your clients to learn from other hiring
managers that are experiencing the same
thing is really useful yeah
i did a lot of the lockdown um
we put a load of round table like
webinar events on
people doing the same job in different
businesses no agenda
an hour call and just let them talk
and it and the just sitting there as a
sort of
as a someone taking part listening to
the conversations the challenges that
they've got
we've been able off the back of that to
think about how we adjust our value
proposition
exactly and off the events that we did
at insight
like we knew of placements that had gone
on behind the scenes that
you know we didn't make a fee off um but
where we got the value is
you know how they met was at an insider
then and when they were looking to
recruit oh
it was that event that we went to that
was great oh it was inside we'll give
them a call
so you started to get in inbound calls
off the back of them
love that so a couple of things
the first thing always get questions
from people around that
recruitment business owner questions
around
hiring yeah so just quickly
when you was in stockport yeah
just you like in obviously your old
office family guys
what was the sell because a lot of
people i've had a lot of messages where
when you're early on on that recruitment
business journey sometimes
you can fall into the trap of being like
why would they want to work
like why would they want to join us or
there's so many other bigger companies
that they could join etc
like i don't know what was the story
that you told these people early on
i think more and more people now aren't
as impressed by the huge
you know bright lights of the large
corporate they want to feel like they're
part of a journey
um and that was that was always the cell
getting now and be part of the journey
the opportunities are endless
um you know feel like part of something
and
accelerate your career in terms of you
know start now in 12 months time you
might be managing your own team because
these are our plans to grow and where
you see yourself fitting in with the um
with our growth we were also quite
fortunate that you know i'd employed a
load of people from from a to zed
sean had a huge network you know we've
been at s3 for 15 years
and anyone in it recruitment or in
recruitment they know who us three years
they probably work there work to one of
the brands or know someone who has
so we're really fortunate that um you
know we had a huge network from that and
both me and sean being from manchester
as well and
we had we had a sort of network to tap
into straight away so
you know a lot of people knew of us um
my success from
my career sean's success at s3 that you
know there was two sort of proven
credible people
at the front of it all um and yeah we
just tried to get people that were
engaged and bought into our vision
and because the you know the reality is
we were in a in an office a regis office
in stockport you know it was a nice
office and it served its purpose but
it wasn't anything compared to what what
you see now in
in manchester with all the weak work
spaces and some of the recruitment
businesses have got you know amazing
amazing places to work but i think most
importantly if they bought into the
leaders and the vision and
see themselves as part of something that
that's it and
you know some of the guys that work for
us have gone off to set their own
companies up and you know that they're
going through that same now but
i think if if they're bought into what
you what you want to achieve and you
i don't think it really matters where
you are or yeah yeah
i love that so strive then
yep back teaming up with harrison
yeah so just a bit of context so how
long has strive been going now
so if i think now started off
officially back end of 2017
and we started trading i think in
january 2018 but
when we started off it uh harrison was
focusing more on
um like entry-level sales people um
more like rep to rack and uh getting
entry-level sales people into sales
roles
um but yeah early early 2018 i think he
started
when we officially started trading so
started there but and then it evolved
into
tech sales yeah so how it came about two
of our clients from insight
we've been placing developers they said
you know you found us the techies can
you find
someone to go out and sell so one of my
big clients um
in huddersfield give us a sales director
role
and then another client of ours in
manchester uh give us
a another of senior sales role
and rather than dilute what insight was
from a like a technical recruitment
business we gave it to harrison and
he smashed both the roles in about three
weeks and both the fees for those two
role
roles are like much higher than any of
the fees we've done on strive or
and the majority of them and insight and
that sort of opened his eyes to think
right you know what i need to move up
the food chain
um and then he just he started going
after your more senior enterprise sales
roles and that was it once he got a
taste for it
and you know knew he could deliver um
he did that and he in in the six months
he did the enterprise stuff
he outbuild all the perm villas on on
inside
really so that was it then
he turned his nose up at the uh
and and and just and then what was your
position then adam in
in inside was it like was you was you
still on the tools was it
like i don't know just just to help me
out what was you doing yeah
i pretty much stayed hands-on like
mostly
because i did a contract a lot of the bd
was
like started off with me booting the
doors down trying to win contract jobs
and if i didn't win a contract
job i'd pass it over to lee who head up
the perm stuff and he'd deliver all the
perm stuff so
a lot of the clients um how he was
involved in some way or another
particularly all of our key accounts
so it was always very hands-on towards
the end i did i
didn't do any much resourcing i'd the
clients would bring me with the jobs and
i'd pass them to some of the contract
team who would deliver to them
and but towards the end we um we really
started ramping up recruitment
and i focused on on training them
so we we started the insight academy
um and then for the last sort of few
months or so i was very much focusing on
training developing people that
that joined us um so yeah towards the
end less hands-on from a resourcing
perspective still involved with clients
we do a lot of client meetings but very
much
focused on trying to get people up
skilled okay
cool so then so then you went full time
on strive from october last year you
said yeah
yeah so i um i took a bit of time off
with uh
with within sight took a couple of
months off when
sort of traveling once around europe and
time in ibiza new york barcelona and
enjoyed myself a little bit and then
came back in may started helping
harrison
really sort of get get strive in a
position where we could start to scale
it because
at the time it's just a small team all
just very much focusing on billing
um so i focused on like making sure we
had the right crm
and getting all the processes in place
all the procedures and getting the
business in a position where we could
start to scale it
started focusing on hiring an ops
manager um who could then really help
sort of get the business ready for us to
you know really start pushing on
um and then yeah we moved moose drive
into its own space
because this sort of became a bit of an
culture with striving inside because
we're doing two very
different markets the fees on strive was
so much higher than insight
and it there was whilst everyone got on
very well it was very much another
kind of yeah um atmosphere so we
decided to separate the two um
and then yeah yeah after like a few
months have focused on that i just
decided that i wanted to
focus 100 of my efforts with strive and
me and sean agreed a deal
um and the era i parted ways with
insight and then
focus 100 with strive and alex and john
then joined us
i was going to say when did they join
you for the final bit of like context
so officially um we just like over the
last couple of months officially like
announced it and signed all the deals
there were um
there was a lot of um a lot of
conversations that were going on for
months but in terms of was actually
putting
pen to paper that's been quite a recent
thing but they've helped massively over
the last few months in terms of
yeah getting the business ready for for
you know
and capable of then scaling so we
started talking with them i think it was
around january and january of last year
i think it was
okay so let's break this down a bit
so what i'm definitely keen to go into
uh adam is
the the whole scaling part because
you've mentioned that a couple of times
i'm getting ready to scale on these
types of things
yeah and i'm i'm sure you have some
knowledge you're aware but
the majority of the uk recruitment
market is sub 10 staff
right and whenever i've spoken to
recruitment business owners that
do scale and grow a profitable
profitable recruitment business that
goes beyond that
what i've always found is common is that
they might be a
not that the head counts are always the
best measurement right but let's just
say
i'm at 10 you're a 10 now like a lot of
people that staying around that and
always
get to 15 then back to 10 and sort of
fluctuate which is really common from
the messages i get and
these types of things it's been really
common that
those that scale and go beyond that
actually have the mindset of where this
is where we are now but
what we're implementing and what we're
having in place and our mindset is that
we're already a 30 person company
um so when you say getting ready for
scaling what does that actually mean
like what's actually involved or what
are the sort of key
things that you've invested in them no
doubt john alex have helped you shape
and put together
one getting you ready to scale
yeah so if i think so first and foremost
alex and john if you look at what they
did from two to 140 full-time you know
absolute dominant market leader in their
space
uh over 100 million turnover sold for
a healthy sum shall we say and got there
what a lot of people call you
their [ __ ] you money kind of thing the
proven track record and
you know that they they've got the you
know they've got the
experience to do it in terms of what
we've been doing
um is you know operationally making sure
that the business is
is ready to go just everything from all
the back office processes
procedures the training documentation
and you know helen has been amazing like
since she's joined and he's had a
transformation of the business
you know everything's got a place
everything's got a process everything
is organized you know the team know
where they're at you know
you know everything just runs really
good who's helen sorry adam who what's
her job title helen she's our ops
manager um
so she she she's been like an absolute
game-changing hire for us
she's worked for john and alex before um
so
so that's that's what again quite common
and you don't really hear often how many
recruitment businesses of 10 people
eight people
sub 10 have an operations manager yeah
so why why if i'm listening right now
why should that be on my roadmap of
hires you said like just like this sort
of real core cell of you need to get an
operations manager sooner rather than
later like why is that important and why
has that massively helped you
so if you think most small business
owners wear a lot of hats
and that's like one of the downfalls and
things that holds them back we're trying
to do too much
so the reason that we brought helen on
was
because she's so good at the operational
side
like her organization attention to
detail is just
like phenomenal and taking that
responsibility away from me and harrison
has allowed me and harrison to focus on
other areas of the business so
when when she's joined my then focus was
recruitment so i spent
three months to like solidly recruiting
we set the bar really high and to hire
three new
trainee consultants develop then push
them on and then just before the
pandemic we're about to push the button
again and start hiring into the three
so that's why you know having someone of
helen's experience
you know was probably a bit premature
for where the business was but
how much that's helped the business has
been like i can't even describe it
um so when we say it's like just to make
it really clear for people because i
think this is the part of that like
as you just said a bit premature but
it's not premature if you know where
you're going or what the intentions are
right
so when we say so obviously as you're
saying it's enabled you to just focus on
the parts that you're good at
you and harrison your strengths
recruitment selling winning clients
revenue generating activities yeah
so are we talking she's helped you with
what like what is the typical thing that
you
have is it like terms of business is it
anything that's not sales related
okay anything that doesn't involve
picking up the phone or delivering to a
job
um or like um i suppose internal
recruitment
she's helped with internal recruitment
in terms of the process and our approach
but in terms of actually doing it but
anything else is
uh helen helen deals with it i have to
ask helen more about
strive than the tipsy guys that's me um
yeah she's literally got the business in
a position where it's ready to to scale
the next key higher we were
we were just started looking at we'd
actually found someone was an internal
recruiter
to come in full-time uh and focus purely
on recruitment
but um i suppose from a we we missed the
target that we wanted to
to hit financially um which sort of
settles back a little bit to think you
know maybe this is just that little bit
too premature
and then obviously the pandemic here and
but that was the next
key hire that we were going to focus on
was having someone focusing 100
on internal recruitment so that i could
then continue focusing on
sales and development of people because
the recruitment piece just took up
all my time the internal recruitment
piece
yeah until we you know obviously hired
the people but those game changing hires
um you know so many people after we
hired helen
so many people that had like worked for
me and gone and set up on their own or
like sean as well and to say like you
know
what's the situation with with helen
light is you know it's a big higher and
there's only like
six of you um and yeah there's a big
like i'd recommend it yeah because it's
because it's the
you're hiring helen and she's not gonna
make you money
but she is on the face of it it's like
adam why
why behind that person because like it's
they don't generate any revenue
but yeah actually they do because it
enables enables you to
it's about viewing your time what your
what
what's most valuable for you to spend
time on and let's be frank she's better
at that than the bet
what she does she's ten times better out
than i am
um because she does does the job better
someone's gonna try and poach her off
the back of it
no i just think that's really
interesting because it that ties into
the whole
premature thinking where you want to be
in the highs that are going to enable
you to do that rather than
now we'll get someone in like helen 20
people don't really need them now
do you know what i mean so that was one
of the i think one of
the our biggest weaknesses at insight
was not having that person we've grown
quick um but i think where the business
fell down was the fact that it was a bit
like organized chaos
um and i think if we had someone like
helen in place
there yeah we could have retrieved a lot
more
and that's the thing if you are planning
to grow and scale your business
don't put that off get that in sooner
and it'll enable you to grow
so what i'd be really keen to talk about
because i feel like it would have
impacted
a lot of things like influencing your
culture
sort of your mindset the the decisions
that you've made
but um so john and alex getting involved
in the business
yeah i'm sure you would have had your
own opinion before obviously
it's great that obviously you knew them
before you got to that stage
but the typical from from what i've
gathered from
speaking to recruiters on this podcast
and through what i do and
stuff the typical perception of
uh someone that can invest in adam
richton and harrison the recruitment
entrepreneurs is that if you go down
that route that they're going to own
your business
and they might take complete control or
they just it from from what i can see
there isn't
the best reputation around people that
invest in recruit
and recruit to start their own business
from what i can see
so i guess why don't we just talk a bit
about that
because i don't know what your
perception was before if that
if you had any of that i'm not sure
they'll take over then we won't have any
i don't know but like what has it
actually been like
having yeah two people that have walked
the walk
and that have actually invested in your
in the recruitment business
yeah so after leaving liquid
and never had any form of external help
uh investment anything i mean harrison
pretty much just did it all
ourselves um and
it never really crossed our mind to get
investment um
or someone not necessarily investing
like external people in
to help us help us grow the business and
when
when we was speaking with alex and john
it wasn't like a financial thing
it was more about what they bring to the
table in terms of fear of someone taking
over your business then
surely like that comes down to the
commercial agreement that you have in
place whether they're in a position to
do that
um and if the kind of people you bring
into the business you've got worry of
them doing that then they're probably
not the right kind of people you want
involved but
having someone like john and alex on
board it's just
it's been great it's been a completely
big change to how we work you know
alex and john hold me and harrison
accountable they're not our bosses
but then they won't shy away for saying
listen you need to pull your finger out
or you're not doing this right or you
said
and how does that work adam because i
think that's one of the most
that's one of the i feel like you said
that first i feel like that's one of the
big benefits right so how does that
actually work is that that
you have like a quarterly board meeting
and you're like right guys this is where
we're at this
these are our goals for the next quarter
whatever and then you
obviously openly communicate this is
where you're at this is where you want
to go
and if you don't hit those certain
things they're going what's going on why
haven't you done it blah blah blah
how does that actually work that
accountability yeah so
we we meet weekly um weekly management
meeting where we discuss all the sort of
ongoing
sort of day-to-day stuff we've got uh
monthly
board meetings quarterly and like
business reviews kind of thing so we
we meet regularly john and alex are on
the end of the phone every day
um if they want to be they're not like
they don't micromanage they're not
breathing down on them they're there
purely as a support framework
that's it you know they have a share in
the business the directors in the
business
they have you know it's in their
interests that we do well but they're
not
i think if you've got an ego and you
can't see yourself having to answer to
anyone
then you might have a problem but if you
can set your ego aside and think you
know what if alex gives me a bollocking
i'm not a bologna but says like calls me
out
he's doing that to help us both and
we've gotta have that situation he's
called me out on something saying that
he said you'd do that
you've not and say my harrison um and he
can be pretty heavy-handed at times
but it's it's in all of us yeah
so accountability what else have they
had a big impact on
so their experience you know the lessons
they've learned
from and you know said you know this is
what happened to us and this is why
we changed the same from my experience
with insight lessons i learned from
there so their experience
also like confidence like you know i was
really
proud of what i did with insight with
with sean
um but also like having someone like
john and alex in your corner
just really gives you that sort of
confidence to sort of really know that
you can push on and achieve
what a lot of people set out to achieve
you know they've got this big plans of
an international recruitment business
but like you said most of them are sub
10.
having someone like john and alex in
your corner gives you that confidence
to to to do it and it's also given us a
bit of
flexibility and knowing that we've got
the resources
um financially if we if we wanted to be
really ambitious or if we
face really like tough times it's sort
of nice to have that as a sort of safety
blanket as well
um but i think we're really lucky we
were like john and alex pretty much
shaped both my inheritance very early
careers like they've had
so much of an influence on us from such
an early stage
we're so fortunate to be in the position
where we are now where
they're now helping us you know ten
years down the line whereas a lot i know
a lot of
relationships with investors isn't
always like that
yeah and i think our situation is quite
unique
um yeah i think the confidence piece is
really interesting because that can
filter into so many positive things
can't it
as a real criminal business owner if
if you you know if you're bringing in it
depends what your reason is for bringing
you know someone like john and alex on
board you know you're doing it because
they add value from their experience or
you're just
doing it because you need the money you
probably need to reconsider
you know am i prepared to give up my
share in the business and
having a complete control for the sake
of
a cash injection that i need or
something along those lines i think you
need to think about your why
and if you don't need to get excellent
external and you've got other ways of
raising capital or whatever it is you
should consider them but
having john and alex on board is is
great and anyone that's looking to
start up or they've already started up
and feel like they've plateaued and they
want to push on
i i can't recommend both of them enough
so just a couple of things on this then
before i ask you the last couple of
questions
what i'd love for you to just sort of do
some key points on so you've said around
the
hiring of helen the operations person
what other things do you think what
other decisions have you made or things
that you've actioned
do you think wouldn't have happened if
john and alex weren't involved
um one of the so one of the things that
alex and john got really
renowned for was their training program
at liquid and they won awards for it
and one of the things i did a lot of
insight was training but it wasn't as
very it wasn't as
structured and formalized so one of the
first things that we put together was
um well first of all was our recruitment
process we absolutely nailed our
recruitment program
we're talking when you're dealing with
clients clients and candidates or
intelligence internal recruitment okay
so yeah um
first one was our internal recruitment
process to make sure that we
really set the barrier really high i
mean i interviewed 100 people
to get to hire one wow so so the first
thing
is yeah so the first thing is if
if they hadn't gotten involved that
would have continued
i would have continued hiring the way
that we hired insight and whilst we had
some amazing people
there was a few bad ones that slipped
through the net it's what you said
it's just it's the actual having a
process it's actually that you wouldn't
put in a process you would have just
kept being reactive or doing what you do
yeah the first things the
internal recruitment process that's
interesting what else and
training development we literally are
our training development is is great
considering the size of the business and
the maturity of the business
where we're at the training and
development program that we've got and
ask
us to ask the guys what their experience
has been like
you know ed who's worked another
recruitment business for
director x that i've seen it and it's
really good and genuinely delivers on
the promises that i know a lot of
recruitment agencies promise consultants
when they join us that you'll get
trained and developed and supported
and i know that you know genuinely i'm
delivering on those promises so
to give you an idea all the three that
we hired at the back end of last year
um i'd had some sort of recruitment
experience but it wasn't the 360 kind of
recruitment so they all came in as
trainees
um and all you know all hit that also
passed the probation all hit the first
um
promotion and have all smashed the
revenue targets
um in their first six months in the job
okay which
you know they've all been given the
tools and the skills to to to do it so
first thing was recruitment process
second thing was our
and training development um and again
making that a process and actually
making that more official compared to
okay so just a quick one on that adam
you said
considering our size or whatever that
that's my question really because
if i'm in a small business like how much
training and development can i actually
deliver because i think that's where
sometimes
people think that they can't they they
can't like how can i make that into a
proper trend development program like
they sit next to me they listen to me
do you know what i mean like how can you
offer
development to someone who's in the
business of the size of yours like what
does that actually look like
so let's be honest like the the the
sitting next to someone listening and
just getting that soaking up the
atmosphere is one of the best ways to
learn
you know just trucking someone in the
deep end they live a sink or swim
but people have different learning
styles you know some prefer classroom
some prefer one-on-one coaching some
people prefer constant feedback
so when helen joined because of her
ability to sort of just take something
in
process yeah yeah systemize it
operationalize it whatever you want to
call it
i just sat with helen for a few weeks
just going through
taking out how we recruit mapping it out
and thinking about
how i would train every single aspect of
the recruitment life cycle
putting videos call recordings uh
training pro
scripts absolutely everything you could
think of
call coaching sessions role plays just
everything that they would need to do so
that by the end of the program they can
if
they can recruit and they've got
something to refer back to alex had a
huge impact in that in terms of him
helping scripting a lot of the stuff
uh how long's the program
um for them to it probably took us it
took us the first three months before
they were all like
sort of self-sufficient way you could
give give give one of
the guys a role and say right here's a
job
you know the brief you're on the call
with the client follow the process and
at the end of it you'll
you'll have some commissioned you love
that
so again we're talking about again this
these are the types of things that
now you've done now where you're at get
get to the first stage or hire five
people you know exactly what they need
to go through
whereas typically yeah okay alex said
something to me said the people from the
process the process runs the business
and that was it they say that the people
from the process the process runs the
business
so if if i say to some of the guys where
you're at with the job
and that they're working on like getting
an update on where they're at with some
of the roles they're working
i just say where are you at in the
process and they'll say i've done this
done that done that and i'm here now
and they'll know that by the time they
get to the end of it they should they
should have multiple interviews on the
job and it should be boxed off
love that mate so we're talking a bit
like a 12-week program
for them to be sort of close to being
self-sufficient but to work for all that
content and no doubt
it's sort of ongoing but yeah so the
next part of that then that i'm
interested in
and to get your thoughts on is then so i
joined your business got this great
training program
um great as you all know one of the sort
of main key motivators for a lot of
people
is development and making sure that i
don't feel like i'm plateauing or
whatever so
how how of you as a small recruitment
business owner that's growing
how can you offer that to me like how
have you then processed or structured
that is it just done on billings and
promotions or like how have you then
ensured that not only have you trained
these people well but you've then
got a clear career development path
yeah so to be frank we strive it's still
early days and you know none of the guys
are really at that point where they're
starting to
like massively push on in terms of their
role diversifying they're still
in the first sort of 12 months as a
recruitment consultant kind of role but
in terms of how we promote it's based on
revenue and then
like values so they've got the skills
and capability to do the next part of
the role whether it's the business
development account management or
leadership
and values you know do they demonstrate
the values that we have
um
and a lot of the other things oh you put
me on the spot here but yeah
it's a combination of you know
performance
and behaviors and attitudes have you
have you have you met i guess what i'm
just trying to ask you
just because i'm interested is like have
you actually mapped out like
because again i feel like smaller
businesses yeah did you get one because
i feel like again smaller businesses
don't typically do that yeah
yeah so we might start out from
literally coming as an associate
right the way through to the um like vp
of sales sales director within the
business
so we give that to the rector x and or
anyone that we approach directly we'll
talk them through
all of the different stages from
associate to
yeah basically running in the office do
you think you would have done that if
you
didn't have john alex involved um
they they they pushed it we had it
inside had it in mind
yeah yeah sean drove it a bit more so at
the end of every year um
sorry the end of every quarter or every
six months we would always do like a
vision meeting where
we would put up an organogram of the
business and where the new roles are
emerging because of our growth and
how a new management role or a new
division or a new market had appeared
because of
what the progress that we've made so
it's something that we always did and
sean always did that really well and
we always found that off the back of
those meetings people you're giving
people a new lease of life
because they'd say oh i want to do that
and then you knew that was important
yeah but i'd say to it definitely wasn't
on my radar to do that within the first
12 months
but it was something that we use to help
attract people
so that again this yeah this is about
yeah that's why i was just keen to get
into that because i think again
anyone that's listens in the smaller
business it's like that you again it's
that it's that
like you want to think long time again
and think this is where we are but we're
going to be here and
that's so important i think that's not a
big big
bigger picture mentality and not just
focus on what's in front of you which i
think me and harrison did a lot of when
we were younger
we were just making money not thinking
about anything long term we're just
thinking about how much can we make this
month and how much should we go and
spanner at the weekend
now now we're thinking a bit more about
right longer term
okay so before we finish them
let's acknowledge the last 12 weeks last
three four months
has i mean leading up to that i don't
know like has it been has that been the
most
the biggest challenge so far since since
since full time on strive
that going through the last 12 there's
two sides of it
from a work perspective it's been tough
um
and like i'm not the most disciplined
person
you know you go on about like recruit
leaders having all this mindset like i'm
not that person that's harrison but he's
in the gym at five every day so
keeping yourself absolutely focused is
not something i'm super
sort of super strong about but work wise
has been really tough
um just because of you know it's been
tough bd
and trying to win business in a market
that we're in now
from a personal perspective um i don't
want this to be insensitive
because a lot of people haven't will
have sort of really struggled during the
last few months but
it's been great i've loved it i've i've
been gifted time
so being able to spend time in the
garden
exercising doing what i want to do so
it's been a bit of a
sort of bittersweet work's been a bit
crap having to
follow everyone and um you know it's
setting us back in terms of
because we're on a really good we're on
a good had some really good momentum
um but from a personal perspective i've
really i think it's been a bit of a
blessing in disguise for a lot of people
what's been the most difficult decision
you've had to make so far though
during the last 12 weeks honestly
i've not we've not had to make any
difficult decisions from it from the
business perspective when
it when so just before the lockdown
i came back in on the monday we worked
on the monday on the tuesday came in and
it started
to get like it took a turn and i think
people started to realize how serious it
was
all of our jobs were literally getting
pulled pulled and it was a bit of a
realization so
the office next door had sent everyone
home so we pulled everyone in the
meeting said listen guys
we're taking the decision if you want to
work from home from now you can and then
they put everyone in lockdown on the
thursday
so we we did that but we we made a
pledge to everyone that
we were gonna do everything we can to to
make sure that no one lose the jobs we
we cut all of our costs back we
negotiated good deals with our suppliers
me and harrison cut our wages back and
we did everything you know
to secure everyone's roles so i've not
had to make
any any difficult decisions because of
the pandemic
um such would so it's we've not had to
do anything like that yet
and then how because i think a lot of
people found obviously
have ended up hands focus on business
development yeah
what's your journey been like that i
know when we spoke a couple of weeks
back that
um yeah i remember because at the
beginning it was like
i'm literally being told like adam how
are you calling me about hiring
like how are you doing that so like i'm
sure that's changed now because i think
it's we've
been through that journey in the last 12
weeks haven't we where it's been like
adam why are you calling me and talking
about recruitment full stop so now it's
like
okay just way more acceptance and
understand this
is a long thing for him for a while so
guess what
how have you navigated through that on
the business development standpoint
because i think a lot of people can
relate to that and get
sort of value from that the
first so the last few weeks of march we
pretty much just took it off
and it didn't do anything and we all
just
like just chilled out took stock and
then got back in around the first week
in april
first week i was just ambulance chasing
just
hunting for jobs and someone said to me
this ambulance chasing approach adam's
not going to work we're not hiring
and when when they said that
me and harrison said i was like we're
wasting our time go
because all of our clients had stopped
recruiting so we had to find new clients
so bringing a new client cold yeah
flipping health pandemic we were pissing
in the wind
so that's when we decided to do the
webinars and
every single call from there i'm not
calling about recruitment i can help you
and then six weeks of that we started to
build relationships with new people
and some of those clients now and have
started to give us work and starting to
having conversations about working
together
and so we just changed the conversation
that we were having
but it took about a week for us to
realize that
and now for the last three weeks we've
started to see
you know conversations jobs coming
through
and i suppose light at the end of the
tunnel but yeah it was
yeah that's smart we just changed the
comp yeah if you've if you've spent the
last
few months just leaving yeah
and you're still you've you know you've
not thrown yourself off a bridge
because i was at the end of a tether
after a week yeah i can imagine
um so look you you've been in the
the game for a while like and obviously
access to
to john alex have been in the industry
for a while as well
like what what does the future look like
for you like how are you thinking about
the future of
strive like spoken to a lot of people
around obviously the whole
like flexible working piece and and so
that's going to change but
i don't know what what does what does
the sort of future or what the things
are you thinking about
sort of going into the next sort of
quarter and beyond
um so at the moment like we've
we've refocused our short-term goals
just to sort of try and get us through
this period
uh the long-term goals stayed the same
in terms of changes in how we work at
the moment we've
we've reduced the hours that we're
working slightly just so that we're not
burning ourselves out
um but in terms of how we think things
will change
i think the people have a lot more
flexibility because it's proven that
people working from home works
so what sort of the fence was you before
i i was always getting the office
harrison's old school
like wall street boiler room you know in
the office yeah
militant and i'm the opposite so like
you know
he'd still be in a three-piece suit if
you had it
um whereas i'm i'm i'm the opposite so
i was always a bit more liberal shall we
say fair enough
okay i think that's going to be
interesting isn't it yeah i think i
think because harrison's so far one side
and i'm so far the other we always end
up
gonna compromise the guys the guys get
treated like grown-ups we'd always treat
anyone that come in like grown-ups
you know if someone wants to work from
home and they've got a genuine reason
for it then
yeah go for it if you can't trust people
to do stuff like that then why do you
hide them in the first place
and if they've broken that trust then
they probably shouldn't still be in the
business
um yeah no i think that that's gonna be
interesting because i think
i think it's just gonna make recruitment
businesses just
evolve differently or open up to the
type of people that they can potentially
hire
i think it's just going to change a lot
isn't it and i think if you're a
recruitment business that still
wants people in five days a week in the
office blah blah blah
i think you'll be missing out on on a
lot of people because now now the
before it was a nice to have before it
was like
adam what's your view and flexible
working is that something that strive
does blah blah blah but now
if you just go like no we don't we don't
do that
they're gonna there's a lot more
businesses that now have that as part of
their
standards the company next door was they
were at the end of their lease and
they've got a new office that they're
moving into they've scrapped the office
and they've
everyone's working from home now really
i know you've seen like the big
twitter and all that you know the big
big tackle
you know a small 20 30 people
office next door to us they've done it
and so
i think it's going to be you know the
norm but i also think that the
the amount of remote working and people
having to work from home in isolation
has also
took the shine off it a lot of people
are excited to get back in the office
yeah i definitely was so yeah i agreed
yeah
i i did nothing at home and i didn't
honestly i do when i was work and then i
go and sit in the garage and play with
my bikes for a couple of hours or
you know just sit and talk to be
distracted yeah
like if i can't do it it's my own
business then
it's something it's one of those well
it's not for everyone is it yeah
i guess so last couple of things before
i asked you the final question adam
yeah what what's helped you
like resi resilience during this period
would have been
one of the most important things right
yeah what's helped you
sort of weather the storm and the the
roller coaster over the last couple of
weeks what's helped you personally like
get through it
yeah so one of the things that you'd
sort of said before that was around
mindset like i i'm not the mindset
kind of you know poster boy that that's
harrison he's the guy that's gonna
you know militant with his diet his
exercise
routine is you know all that kind of
thing but um you know i'm quite a
resilient person
um but normally when things go sort of
tips up i go into self-destruct to just
go and have a skin full somewhere but
then everything has to sort me out but
what's got me through the last few
few um few months or so is yeah we've
got a clear vision that we want to
achieve as the business
but from a personal standpoint i think
there's nothing
revolutionary here just a lot of
exercise like i'm massively into my
biking
sort of motorbiking push biking i've
just yeah i just kept
kept myself fit and that's what's got me
through it um
and then from a work perspective having
him breathing down the neck saying why
aren't you in the office
nice fair enough um
okay what are you most excited about
post covered mate
very soon honestly
so i'd never want to sort of wish bad on
anyone but i think
this whole pandemic is going to see a
lot of [ __ ] leave the market
from a recruitment perspective a lot of
bad recruiters are going to
try and find an easier way to make a
living it's going to be better for
clients because they're not going to be
dealing with poor levels of service from
recruitment
recruiters and there's going to be more
opportunity for those that survive so
like
churchill said you're going through hell
keep going and i'm hoping that
we keep going through this and we're
going to come out the other side
there'll be less people in the market
and
when that when we get the bounce back
there'll be more opportunities so i i
think that
yeah if you can survive this and you can
work through this then
i don't think there's going to be much
that can test you um
in a commercial sense okay
final question yeah if adam could
communicate to every single recruiter
out there could be a business owner
recruiter
they'd listen to advice they'd take it
on it could be a phrase a sentence a
word
what would you say what would you say to
the people
right i wish you'd have prepped me on
this one though
um i think if you're starting out in
recruitment
then you know recruitment's a long-term
thing a lot of people come out of
university and they see recruitment as a
get-rich-quick scheme it's not like you
do it takes a while one of the
one of the examples that um sean always
gave when we were hiring new people is
when he started s3 it took him six
months to do his first placement
and the second six months he was you
know he did really well so
you've got to really think about you
know this is like a
three four five year plan if you really
want to sort of smash it in recruitment
from an earning potential so don't think
this is going to be a quick win
and think about the long term everything
that you're doing day to day is going to
ultimately
pay dividends um so
so yeah you know just keep you know
think about think about it in the long
term and don't
think this is a going to be a short-term
fix make sure that you've got
some real goals that you're working
towards and i think if you've got
something that you're working towards
that makes the day-to-day a lot more
bearable
if i think about times when i've been
disengaged and couldn't really be
bothered with workers because it wasn't
really working
towards anything i like to like if i put
myself under pressure
like stretch myself financially or
whatever it is
i work better so have you know put
yourself under pressure
and have have clear goals and if you're
thinking about starting up your own
recruitment company
um give it a go give it a go
i love that adam it's been actually
pleasure mate
thank you